I think that creating something like
Jack and the Beanstalk with the ability
to climb your way into heaven it's
probably still maybe a hundred years
away however we're making enormous
inroads with carbon nanotubes and
graphene ever since the 1800s we knew
that a space elevator was physically
possible if we could create a substance
that was stronger than steel well now we
have such a substance these are carbon
nanotubes and graphene graphene is the
hardest substance known to science on
the entire planet Earth graphene is so
strong that you can take an elephant put
the elephant on a pencil balance the
pencil on a sheet of graphene and
graphene will not tear well if graphene
is so powerful that why can't we make
this ladder to the Stars
the problem is strictly technical the
largest amount of pure carbon nanotubes
and graphene that we can make in the
laboratory is about that big we need
thousands of miles of pure cable in
order to create a space elevator the
problem with going to the stars is only
the first few hundred miles if you can
negotiate the first few hundred miles
and get off the gravitational well of
the planet Earth you're well on your way
to going to the stars themselves that's
why a space elevator could literally
revolutionize space travel
however the technical problems are still
enormous satellites travel at 18,000
miles per hour the space elevator will
probably not sustain a direct hit with a
satellite going at 18,000 miles per hour
and what happens in case of a monsoon or
a hurricane on the planet earth you
would want to anchor the space elevator
to some point on the earth but it has to
be flexible again because what happens
when a hurricane rips right through your
territory and perhaps rips the space
elevator so there are a lot of technical
questions that still have to be
addressed but in principle a space
elevator is within the laws
you